welcome everyone we're gonna get started
welcome back from Spring Break and
welcome back to the auditorium I won't
say much what I will say is we're very
pleased to have Keller back here you
were here a few years ago so it's a
pleasure and I won't say anything more
because Felicity Scott is an old friend
of Keller's and she will make a proper
introduction thank you thanks Ben so I
just actually wanted to begin by saying
that I was very excited when I saw a
Keller's name on the poster at the
beginning of the semester and and it's
really an honor to be in the position of
welcoming you and and introducing your
work briefly prior to your presentation
of the lecture which is entitled
disposition I just want to say that
Keller's contribution I think is really
unparalleled in the field of
architecture not only in its content
which as you probably know is incredibly
wide-ranging but in the manner in which
she display deploys what as you'll see
is really sort of intense intelligence
and a formidable research capacity that
we might say often sort of tracks the
money you know the monetary mechanisms
and other political and geopolitical
logistics to unstitch the relations
between what she calls special products
and techniques of power and she does
this again as you'll see with this
incredible rhetorical elegance and a
sense of irony or wit that such that I
think one often finds himself in the
middle of the most bizarre situations
and costs of characters yet pirates and
fools etc while experiencing a genuine
epiphany about the field near the field
of architecture and in general terms I
guess we might say that that she works
at the Nexus of architecture yeah
architecture and logistics of
organization and certainly at this sort
of sites of switching as as we find them
in infrastructural networks and again
networks both material and as I
mentioned sort of informatics and so for
instance just to talk about this Nexus
she has referred to the Depression era
FH house as a protocol for formatting
the land a protocol that interfaces of
course with the banking system and the
labor system in the service of private
capital and so all of this together is
what Keller would call infrastructure
yeah in a sense
infrastructure then understood as
underlying techniques of political
organization so Keller is currently an
associate professor of architecture at
Yale University where she's taught since
1998 both in the studio curriculum and
also in the history and theory of
architecture and urbanism as well as
what we know as globalization or an in
colorist rhetoric really sort of
globalization space prior to that she
was a faculty member here at Columbia
where she played a foundational and
really crucial role in the school's
digital turn in the in the rise of of
the so-called paperless studio which
Keller was teaching as early as 94 I
think uh and so I just wanted to say
that then this means is that well hello
as you know teaching and writing on
computers and experimenting with digital
networks and formats some of us like
myself were still like learning how to
use pine and for those of you who are my
age pine was a email program like with
an incredibly basic interface also
really a that early she produced a
laserdisc project called call it home
the house in private enter part that
that private enterprise built with a
filmmaker richard Prelinger but what i
want to insist on certainly in regard to
the people of studio and then the
digital turan is that that what she
brought to that field certainly at that
moment but also something that continues
in her work today is a decidedly sort of
political mode of analysis wonder that
situates ethical and political
questioning is absolutely central to
what the architect does or
do so then covers accomplishments yeah
Awards public lecturers exhibitions etc
far too numerous of course to outline
here so I just wanted to briefly mention
her major books and we could also
mention that she's a practicing
architect with her own office here in
the city and beyond that even an
accomplished playwright yes incredible
so in 2005 MIT press published enduring
innocence subtitled global architecture
and its political masquerades a story in
six parts which suggests that
architecture might take on a very
different type of political imagination
it looks in her words as designer
website actually it looks at the
political misadventures of special
products the Teflon formulas for resorts
ports retail IT campuses and other
Enclave formations amongst which we
might add golf golf courses um that
store as she puts it yes door likes it
materialized a very crafty political
disposition acquiring myths desires and
symbolic capital they may be objects of
desire and contention in negotiations
between warring countries messy
democracies and violent distended
conflict and just to give you a sense of
the the texture of that book there's one
chapter called el ejido I don't know how
you pronounce that in Spanish a chapter
about Spanish green house Agri poles
that deals with questions of labor of
migration between southern Spain and
North Africa obviously questions of food
energy alternative energy young really
maps the the spatial politics of hytrek
agriculture in the context of of migrant
workers another chapter called I love
DPRK investigates Highland eyes a cruise
ship tourist resort at mount kumgang in
North Korea yes or the incredible body
of research and so it's a body for
search that tracks what she calls outlaw
facial products yeah enclaves really
deployed as political pawns in
jurisdictional battles
formula what I wanted to say then is
that if the the golf courses the moles
the the touristic sites these sites of
agribusiness might initially seem to be
a sort of degraded material or material
rightfully relegated to the realm
outside of architecture as in her words
unresponsive to recognized systems of
architectural language what color
recognizes in them are incredibly
important lessons for the discipline
lesson certainly about global politics
and its manifestation in certain
typology so that's to say that if they
seem to lie outside that the codes and
institutions of architectural practice
proper they nevertheless give rise to
legible dispositions since I imagine the
title of her lecture tonight or
organizations that is they sort of
provide evidence of the disciplines
relation to power and hence also sort of
insist on opening potential tactical
spaces that spaces to practice instead
of otherwise I just mentioned very
briefly in 1999 MIT published her
organization space landscapes highways
and houses in America a project
obviously based in a different
geographical location and with a
entirely different cast of characters we
find Benton MacKaye incredible research
on mid-century environmentalism people
like Gregory Bateson the interstate
highway system all of speaking to new
spatial or some new properly speaking I
guess a new sort of organizational logic
so I'm gonna stop here just to say I
could of course go on and and I just
wanted to finish by saying that if I
were to characterize Keller's work and
her contribution in the briefest
possible way I would say that what she
does is sort of forges new concepts yeah
and with them new potential strategies
for the field for the field of
architecture in a way that I think we
should all take very very seriously
so welcome Keller and we look forward to
your deck you tonight
thank you thank you thank you felicity
well a lecture is always a dialogue to
some extent but but here in this room
where there's so many people I admire
it's a dialogue that I truly enjoy so my
brothers and my sisters
this evening I wanted to offer a
contemplation about recent research on
global infrastructure as a medium of
polity but I also wanted to contemplate
with you the ways in which
infrastructure studies tutor other
artistic and political faculties and
expand repertoire for form making and
activism infrastructure in this research
includes not only physical networks made
of concrete or or microwaves for
transportation or communication for
instance but but also those shared
protocols of Technology urbanism and
markets that format global exchanges and
spatial products the management styles
the routines of logistics the global
regulating standards the the shared
operating system infrastructure space is
often treated as a binding medium or the
current between objects that do have
form name law or as the word suggests
infrastructure is often regarded as a
substrate that's beneath somehow hidden
rather than expressed as positive form
yet yet far from being hidden some
infrastructural formations press
interview a hyperbolic cartoon of their
abstract technical and economic logics
if if infrastructure includes repeatable
formulas for global urbanism the spatial
products are free zones that manifest in
gigantic world city formations these
infrastructures are not hidden within
another urban structure they are the
urban structure and some of the most
radical changes to the globalizing
being written not in the language of Law
and Diplomacy but rather in the spatial
infrastructural manifest of architecture
and urbanism
and it's generating forms of polity
faster than official political channels
can can legislate them then you know
whether hidden or overt on an
international scale the parliaments that
determine everything from free zone
logistics to credit card thickness to
microwave densities or the locations for
submarine cables at the bottom of the
sea are obscure and at a remove from a
more familiar legislative process so
these sometimes mundane sometimes
surprising infrastructures become a
medium of extra state polity tied to
massive global systems administered by
mixtures of public and private cohorts a
Wilder mongrel than any storied
Leviathan for which we have a studied
political response so the book I'm
working on now titled
extra statecraft is a portmanteau that
suggests outside of and in addition to
the state extra statecraft tries to sift
through the thickening layers of
governance that far from superseding the
state often reinforced it with new
powers and proxies so for us you know
weary of the tedium of the rhetorical or
bored with the extent of our influence
or bored with our parochial disciplinary
knowledge that an alternative to a stale
selection of theory is a stale approach
to the real it's it's exciting to find
in this material for me a refreshed
theoretical palette study of these sorts
of technical that we call home socio
technical networks draws us into a field
that falls between a social sciences the
arts business history of science and
architecture and it returns evidence of
cables own standards etc with which we
need to deal but it but it also offers
other
artistic seductions other strata of
political instrumentality artistically
infrastructure studies might tutor
aesthetic practices with active forms
and dispositions and and politically
they tutor the census that that takes
advantage of these powerful sometimes
discrepant forms within broad
foundational transformation see changes
matrix spaces infrastructure stories
sometimes organized history and
sometimes remain the ghost of histories
within the dominant Epis teams
infrastructure is often theorized in
terms of nation-building militarization
Universal rationalization of
cosmopolitanism infrastructure has been
trained to reinforce the cults of
closets or train to demonstrate some
elementary particle in political or
economic science we're seen to be the
very material to rationalize a shared
platform of government so we expect the
right story and political dissent has
has shaped oppositional stances against
those very histories and and both
frequently assume monastic or binary
structures the monism of Ultimates and
utopias or the binaries of enemies and
innocence and in combative face-off and
this go perfect with with the dramatic
swagger we assume when we approach a
political architecture now something
that's sort of themed to be political
that goes to borders and battlegrounds
and barricades surrounded by the
heraldry and theme music of Empire
multitude and total war and in this way
structurally the grand strategies and of
the left and the right even share a kind
of structural resemblance in a zero our
statement come Gilbert and Sullivan
lyric we can hear really a saying I am
read seriously by the French military
and the activist repertoire customary
result relies on among other
things resistance refusal and charitable
volunteerism accompanied by tragic areas
of collusion or co-optation end games of
activism often foreclose on the very
change it wishes to instigate meanwhile
power escapes finding the loophole to
those end games power or what simply
wanders away from the bullseye or where
wriggles out to take shelter in another
ruse change rarely follows sanctioned
plot lines but rather often pivots
around phantom turning points that
aren't so easily taxonomy door moralized
within orthodox political logics beyond
our well rehearsed political scripts and
recognized forms of sovereignty or
events that may not have an orthodox
political pedigree but nevertheless
create a shift in sentiment or a
cessation of violence or return in
economic fortunes and the notion that
there is a proper forthright realm of
political negotiation usually acts as
the perfect camouflage for these truly
consequential circumstances and proxies
we expect the right story when it's
often the wrong story the unlikely story
a little epidemic of rumor and duplicity
that really rules the world
Goliath finds a way and poses David or
multiple forces assembling and
shape-shifting with even more replaced
that fantasy Goliath of monolithic
capital or corporate culture with even
more insidious moving targets and
dissent is left shaking it to this day
at an effigy or curing its failures with
another purification ritual we're making
of the opponent an even more mystical or
vaporous air force of capital and Empire
liberalism and even you know distracted
by the pyrotechnics of war the dramatic
pyrotechnics of war we miss other
stealthier forms of violence we missed
the other consequential politics there's
somehow happening over our shoulder so
there's no there's a time to stand up
and give it a name
and as they say and the pure andhrite
should be allowed to remain undisturbed
and perpetually right but we might
become the clandestine perhaps even
unwelcome exhilarate activism at moments
when it needs an expanded repertoire or
when it might be better not to keep
pushing too hard on an open door the
trap door out of these epic or tragic
narratives is found in the very evidence
they deny while in common pylons the
census is often used to describe the
opposite of consensus and a condition
that needs remedy Ron series used the
word positively as the opposite of
institutional isomorphism the census
considers the contradictions to
consensus insists on what's considered
that inadmissible and as extra state
craft offers some inadmissible and some
evidence that inadmissible to some cults
of history and some notions of descent
proper and I hope opens on to a fresh
pasture in which to work in the case of
infrastructure this fresh pasture is
always all around us and we already know
it it's really only an altered habit of
mind that makes it available to us after
all it's a it's a world where Walmart
the most egregious offender with regard
to health care coverage of its employees
reappears as the purveyor of digitized
health records a world where you can't
smoke a cigarette but you can buy a gun
a world in which building envelopes
inflate and deflate like currency while
we you know in the main are still
training to create firm itas and they
light a world where some of the most
sophisticated high-speed rail projects
are being tried in the Middle East at
the epicenter of oil a world where the
Tea Party movement is successful and
thrillingly where rod Blagojevich a man
with nothing
his hand is still playing these
inversions and outlying political
evidence with their fickle the
underexplored logics excite feelings of
resourcefulness and ingenuity within the
political imagination here is a large
field of mongrel events and category
leftovers butterflies that aren't pinned
to the board because they don't
reinforce our customary political
scripts work they reset our accustomed
narratives we find they're actually
surprisingly you know rather than tense
resistance and competition rather than
head-to-head binary stances some of
those are alternative techniques may
ironically rely on just the opposite the
power of gifts exaggerated compliance
rumor misdirection comedy distraction
contagion like pandas think of the
pandas the China offered to Taiwan named
Tuan Tuan and Yuan Ron names which when
translated meant unity the Panda is the
steamroller
sweetness and kindness it's the means of
controlling leveraging others while
appearing to be chirpy and sweet
anything but the tense grip of
resistance at the margins is supposed to
be collusion with the centre
capitulation but consider exaggerated
compliance think of the moment in
domination and the arts of resistance
when James see Scott draws attention to
a portion of Milan Kundera's the joke in
which the prisoners in the story are
challenged to a relay race against the
camp guards and of course they're
supposed to lose the prisoners decide to
run very slowly against the sprinting
guards while wildly cheering each other
on and this elaborate pantomime and
their their compliance brings them
together in an act of defiance that
doesn't diminish or tax their energies
with competition and fighting of course
exaggerated compliance could disarm can
deliver independence from Authority just
as comedy can deliver critique while
distracting and defusing tensions
Francois Roches dusty relief was
designed to be to electrostatically
attract dust from the polluted air in
Bangkok until it became an adorably
flocked fuzzball
and neither pollution nor prescription
are named as they would be in sort of
not so funny jokes of postmodern
architecture now there's only a sort of
hapless self-deprecating activity that
Foster's sympathetic resourcefulness and
enthusiasm but it's never very smart to
try to describe why something is funny
it's why we should pause in the pasture
to recognize of all these things pandas
and Blagojevich's and right wing tactics
are significant not because of what they
declare their name their extensive
content but because of activity that
manages to evade name declaration and
reckoning it's not what's being said but
how it's playing
it's the spin it's the English on the
ball these are active forms that possess
disposition spaces are rarely considered
to possess disposition and the notion of
active forms would to many seem almost
oxymoronic a building landscape interior
might be described in terms of its
appearance geometrical composition
visual pattern spaces are considered to
be objects volumes not actors or a with
agency or temperament disposition as
it's considered in philosophy in the
social sciences an aesthetic really only
tells us what we already know the word
flourishes in common parlance and
usually describes an unfolding
understanding temperament or relative
position or tendency propensity in
either beings or objects Francoise
Julien gives the example of a ball on an
incline
and a round ball on an inclined plane as
a situation possessing disposition a
propensity associated with the factors
with factors including geometry and
position and we might consider this an
active form in fact if I was to create
active form as we said it would be
oxymoronic to some and for designers
designers might naturally rely on what
their best trained to create of a formal
object that themed or choreographed or
addressed up to represent action we
might use geometry to immobilize a
process like relativity your embryology
or the diagram with choreographed
serialized geometric patterns or you
know in grasping for the apprehension of
an evolving spatial field with changing
components the architect designs the
field in its entirety with a fixed
architectural pattern and the more the
more complex or agitated these tracings
the more active the form is intended to
be and it's still more simple-minded
confusion made more powerful by being
simple-minded would associate action
with movement or dynamism but
disposition locates activity not in
movement but in relationship or relative
position the ball doesn't have to roll
down the hill they have disposition a
glass is brittle without being shattered
this position never has to create a
verifiable event that's that's the point
while you couldn't describe the
disposition of the moving cars in this
slide it's the active form eminent in
the concrete that really interests us
the physical objects in spatial
arrangement and infrastructure static as
they may be possessed agency and
disposition ordinary language
philosopher Gilbert Ryle delighted in
these confuses that arose between
nominative and infinite
the exact mistakes that an architect
would make when thinking about active
form between as he says knowing that and
knowing how he he also knew was not
smart to try to describe what it's funny
he said you cannot ask the question like
what is funny funny is knowing how not
knowing that the clown or the or the
comedian is not providing the right
answer to what is funny he modulates
fluid and plastic expressions in
relation to the reactions of the
audience what's funny is contingent on a
set of possible pathways and choices
from from royal to Irving Goffman to
Latour
those who discuss active forms
inevitably you know in there of course
they're writing and then we return to
performance to advance their argument it
you know because it is one of those arts
that's up to its elbows in action when
it sets up to work and as long since
naturalized working with the infinitive
and the nominative together in theater
the actor loves the rhythm of the sound
the content of the text just as the
architect takes pleasure in geometric
contour but the actor also takes
pleasure in manipulating both the
content of the text together with what
the character is doing now rarely
relying on text alone the actor does not
play in the nominative you don't go to
onstage and play being a mother um it
doesn't can't you you play in the
infinitive you play smothering the child
you play some infinitive expression the
disposition is also not about aesthetics
as the connoisseur ship of the object in
its profile or affect it it adds to
those pleasures associated with shape
and contour the pleasures and seductions
of active forms of ramify effects and
behaviors associated with making making
action making relationship and since
since there is here
something akin to the the juicy piece of
meat that distracts the watchdog of the
mind that McLuhan talked about ice was a
sister aphorism of the medium is the
message we could say the action is the
form stop stumbling further into the
pasture we consider contagion sore or
multipliers active forms not at odds
with but but rather it propels expands
the power of form as object the designer
of active forms is designing the Delta
the means by which an organization
changes not not the field in its
entirety but the way the field is
inflected the way an alteration
multiplies across a field or
reconditions of population or generates
a network so while perhaps intensely
involved with material with geometry all
those things we have in our hand active
forms are inclusive of but not limited
to enclosure and may move beyond the
conventional architectural site but to
to form as content object outline active
form adds modes of authorship with
time-released powers and cascading
effects you know the entrepreneur knows
how to make active forms while an artist
or an architecture reformer may wish to
author an attributable object that
reveals their soul and and alters the
world with a permanently useful or
memorable object the entrepreneur does
exactly the opposite the entrepreneur
working with active forms wonders what
the other person wants and how to get
them to have changeable desires that
supersede and refresh and reverse the
products and plans he introduces into a
population Walmart health records so
here is a sort of a common art for
shaping the object as well as the way
the object plays the shape of the game
piece as well as its repertoire the
disposition is one of the means by which
forms become infrastructural
changing matrix changing game changing
carriers of aesthetic practices
political trajectories that may even be
located at a remove in space and time
consider the double further tutoring and
expanded political repertoire these
active forms are capable of embodying
discrepancies and slippery undeclared
forms of power action is discrepant ron
sierra describes how flow bears madame
bovary relayed to its audience
liberating disposition despite its roots
in conservative politics it was the
content of the story
it wasn't the content of the story but
the way the story was written what the
story was doing that communicated and
and Ron Sierra makes a distinction
between aesthetics that concern what is
being depicted versus what is being done
I mentioned Erving Goffman social
sociologist Erving Goffman uses the word
disposition to describe the entire
performance to the spoken words gestures
postures facial expressions that we all
use in presenting ourselves he noted
that in these myriad subtext often
overwhelmed what's actually being stated
the actor knows that too
the actor knows they're not only just
playing the mother they're not enacting
a text they may speak the line I love
you but while playing an action or
intention to murder with that love
Levittown house may be called colonial
although it's real composition is
unrelated to that name Bilbao may be a
panda an under exploited panda but the
double is an extremely useful form of
discrepancy for instance again with
gratitude to the right-wing for their
instruction the tea party protest is a
double a mirroring of the left I'm using
epithets I like of the left
you know like fascists to describe Obama
the double has magical powers a word
used to identify power a master
fear and hatred is able to instigate
fear and hatred while the dfangs the
term in its previous usage and
inoculates the the present user it's an
active form it's dispositional it
doesn't matter what's being said but
what it's doing extra stick craft drops
down into one nexus of urban
infrastructure that's a double the zone
free trade zones export processing zone
special economic zones are among scores
of zone variants they're typically a
switching point in global trade a space
of exemption from taxes from labor or
environmental really regulation but the
zone has been breeding promiscuously
with many other enclave campus or part
formats until it has become a double
zone is an ancient form heir to ancient
pirate enclaves the free ports of the
han ciothes or the easterling's i am
these are my people that he's doing who
are regional
sort of free trade crooks in 1934
emulating three port laws in hamburg the
US established foreign trade zone status
just reports and warehouses related to
trade i don't you know warehouses
it's like long fences around them but as
the zone merged with manufacturing
export processing zones appeared in the
50s and 60s like the maquiladoras
china's special economic zones allowing
for an even broader range of market
activity emerged in the 70s the zone now
murders with offshore facilities
tourists compounds knowledge villages IT
campuses cultural institutions more and
more programs and spatial products
thrive and this legal lacunae and
political quarantine until the zone has
become a paradigm of a new world city on
the Dubai Singapore Hong Kong model it's
offering the clean slate one-stop entry
into
country and special zones of various
types have grown exponentially so for my
handful and mid-century to a few hundred
by the end of the 20th century to many
thousands now operating in 130 countries
employing them enormous number of people
they are now 66 different names for
different legal cocktails of zone some
are a few hectares in size some are
hundreds of kilometers in size moreover
in in a sort of beautiful example of
extra statecraft
the nation is now engineering its own
zone double national capitals have their
own soft own doppelganger or shadow city
so the zone that used to look like this
or this or this it's become a city with
a full complement of programs a place
where petrol dollars get away to relax
Nobby Mumbai is the double of Mumbai
Qaddafi's Misurata free zone doubles
Tripoli in a sight of actually ancient
Phoenician trading new Songdo city is a
double of Seoul Incheon free trade zone
the free zone Astana as a replacement of
the capital of Almaty and Kazakhstan is
in a move or surpassing irony the zone
as the national capital itself so
because of the impossibility of
reconciling the legal entity residing in
the space of exemption from laws it
floats free unencumbered from
reconciliation and truth it's it sort of
protected in an oscillation between
identities we should have tea parties
but of course this is the power of
meaninglessness and irrationality
enduring innocence set about to look at
these highly rationalized special
products that as they became more
rationalized became better vessels of
rituals and irrationality
and it found this fuzzy religiosity in
golf courses and cream puffs and
Kingdom's global infrastructures - are
supposed to be the great rationalizes of
exchange think of San Simone's belief
that the railroad would create a form of
global governance or arthur c clarke
proposal for global governance with
satellite TV but those proposals also
filled with the same confounding false
logics and drop out between projected
program and reality from organization
studies another discipline which
infrastructure with which infrastructure
studies intersects john mayer writes
global society is a rationalized world
but not exactly what one would call a
rational one the extra state craft also
drops down into the infrastructure of
international and transnational
organizations they're supposed to be
enacting this rationalizing process
their numbers have been accelerating in
post-world War two Pax Americana you
know from from those moments of the
creation of the World Bank the IMF the
OECD and those kinds of organizations
but but further ballooning in the late
20th century proliferation of NGOs I
NGOs IGS and nonprofit organizations of
all types
so from gnomes several hundred it
mid-century to thirty five thousand
today or maybe double that many are
headquartered in U n style Assemblies in
Geneva a Vatican of sorts for
international organization but a
peculiar parliament of this consistent
of this consensus is ISO of the
International Organization for
Standardization founded in 47 I so as a
meta organization it's an organization
of organizations and a crossroad for the
exchanges of of many most
of these international organizations
after World War two
ISO convened many national standards
organizations that they had just been
ensuring consistency and munitions in
the first and second world war and they
develop and certify adherence to
thousands of technical standards so they
ensure that credit cards are 0.76
millimeters thick and slide through any
slot and they they ensure that screw
threads of the pitch of screw threads or
dashboard pictograms battery life and
size ball bearings Footwear lubricants
internet protocols they work on all of
that and have for these many decades
seemingly innocuous deadly boring but
ISOs real dreams of universalization
reside in incantations of something
called quality and it's why the
ubiquitous phone voice promises that
your call will be monitored for quality
assurance purposes quality has history
quality control inspections in the
factory you know at some point began to
evolve to address Quality Assurance or
customer satisfaction so what quality is
is an isomorphic management style it can
be applied to anything from a restaurant
to an automobile manufacturer introduced
in 1987 the ISO 9000 series that's the
name of the the quality standards are
the most popular series and they're
taken up all around the world to
lubricate transactions in both business
and governance here's a global cloud of
certified adherence to ISO 9000 and ISO
9000 is really just a very short
nonspecific tautological list of
statements about customer focus or
leadership or people
people processes systems approaches that
kind of thing
summarized with the acronym PDCA
plan-do-check-act
which is not to be confused with P ODST
o RB P OCCC c WQ c c SS b b and other
scores of acronyms that are part of this
quality culture the management gurus in
the US like Peter Drucker or Edward
Deming or Joseph Juran influenced the
the improvement of post-war Japanese
production techniques in the 70s and
when Europe and the United States
finally awoke to that they began to
import Japanese versions of quality now
more spiritualize mandalas of of
management known as total quality
management new sets of principles and
mandalas and mottos and charismatic
leaders continually emerged this is Six
Sigma a set of quality techniques that
Motorola developed and shared in 1988
you can be you can be a certified black
belt in Six Sigma
but standards are also becoming soft law
for instance the European Union has
encouraged the adoption of of ISO 9000
guidelines as a condition with of entry
as a condition of trade policies and
since ISO believes that quality is the
universal form it's based its
environmental standards not on on
technical benchmarks for emissions but
rather on the ISO 14000 series which is
a management that encourages attitude
shifting sort of and among their their
first initiatives was massaging thought
about the way buildings should be built
so a car company can be ISO 14000
certified you see you get the picture
like so much of the ISO speak it's not
what the forum is saying but but what
it's doing this is the this is the
you AE quality mark quality management
standards that motivates so much of
Industry have more recently expanded
their marketplace faith to serve
healthcare education and government so
you're in a hospital you see pyramids
all over the hospital that are about
excellence you hear the Provost talking
about excellence and action plans and
these same inspirational gurus are
whispering advice to the government's
not of just corporations but of
countries so in another double the
makers of extra statecraft are also
managing government procedures
conflating customers and citizens
government agencies hire quality
engineers presidents hire quality
engineers quality standards join with
John Myers called a modern binge of
organization and the sort of
organization is religion snomint on but
this is the beautiful babbitt ask
nonsense that at the center of not only
corporations but governments but it's
excites a political imagination
considering matrix change in matrix
change you don't square up to every weed
in the field you change the chemistry of
the soil extra state craft drops down
into networks of mobile telephony and
tangles of fiber optics at the bottom of
the sea and through it we can trace a
much longer history of cabling for
instance that extends back to coaxial
cable and telegraph cable and the story
is ill fitting within nation building
histories of infrastructure or
totalizing conceptions of infrastructure
and militarization massive global
infrastructures were he really to such a
large degree the result of not just
national competition and war but
independent multinational enterprises
like the u.s. rail at the end of the
19th century the largest business
enterprise in the world for several
decades employed three times as many
workers as in
u.s. military and incubated really
incubated the managerial culture from
which I so derives or let's it's same
similar with with telegraph cabling a
similar enterprise with massive global
reach and coaxial and and fiber follow
many the same roots as tell it the
coaxial and fiber that followed that are
also laying in the bottom of the seat
followed many of the same roots as the
telegraph but if we look at the new
explosive growth of communication
technologies since satellite and fiber
within and from the point of view of say
the non-aligned countries where so much
of this explosive growth is happening
there's much to be learned and there may
be no better place to sample this
network of fiber optics then and then to
look at the last place on earth to get
fiber-optic submarine cable East Africa
and here I'm looking at Kenya this is my
Robi english-speaking forty percent
unemployment in the last few years
Kenya's gone from having no fiber optic
cable to having three cables teams and
c-calm just came online in June and July
easy just landed in South Africa about a
month ago but until recently they've
been relying on satellite broadband
that's not only at inadequate but it
costs twenty to forty times but it
doesn't know the parts of the world so
what you know what costs you $20 is
costing hundreds of dollars fed up with
negotiations with the World Bank and net
pad of the African Union can you made
its own deal with Etisalat of the UAE
and teams was the first cable to arrive
and the histories to protracted to talk
about now but but basically the the
disputes were over whether the cable
would be open access something we still
don't have in the United States today
yeah and the cable will stretch along
the road from Mombasa to Nairobi
supporting not only new forms of
urbanism but new forms of agriculture
and it's going on very well worn paths
like a stretch
of Cecil Rhodes Cape to Cairo railway
that you see pictured here and not on
the UAE but also China and many ISPs and
mobile telephony entrepreneurs are
poised other opera entrepreneurs have
been laying fiber along the Mombasa
Nairobi Carter in the hopes of growing
export processing zones and calling
centres doctor and demo the minister who
managed the team's deal wants to spread
fibre deeper into the villages so that's
the that's the map he would like to see
and along the Mombasa Nairobi Road or
any zones but zones have been breeding
so promiscuously in the world that
sometimes they favor their recessive
traits in Kenya the zone doesn't
prohibit labor unions it promotes labor
unions it becomes the place of labor
organization in a kind of anti zone and
I so will be there certifying to the
world but these are zones are ready
ready for for business but what form
will this matrix change take it if the
zone might be bred to be its opposite
how might it further change how do you
get your hands on it instruments like
Google trader in Tanzania you maybe
you've heard of it it's an online
marketplace that allows farmers to
bargain with a little more foreknowledge
of where they go to market they will be
you know not themselves enclosures or
urban isms or urban Azure spaces of
urbanism or landscape but they will be
active forms that generate those
physical forums so how do we use them in
inflect them with our expertise about
space and volume just to the north and
Khartoum Sudan on the confluence of the
white and blue nile the Alma grande
developments developed with the friends
the help of our friends from the UAE
will offer 1600 acres of sort of zonal
world city that
thing that exacerbates violence between
the north and this house so we it goes
without saying it's in some ways it's
entirely obvious but the notion of
disposition stretches to address agency
or temperament these spaces and networks
can be evaluated for the ways in which
they're they're taken see their closure
that positioned their arrangement
possesses for instance a quotient of
aggression submission exclusivity it's a
whole other hour of hours discussion but
this position is imminent in
organization but finally contemplate
Rumer the right wing instructs us
further about the active form of rumor
for instance the rumor that that Obama
was Muslim was brilliant precisely
because was wrong and easy to disprove
it was repeated twice as twice as often
first to spread the rumor and then to
refute it the hoax the global warming
was a hoax was again their brilliant
doubling so inspired by by brilliance
like this some true stories researches
in the field of flexible truth it was an
exhibition at the storefront for art and
architecture in the fall of 2008
rehearse the design of active forms in
this case the confidence game of design
as it moves through and persuades
culture the material presented was
partially true what in Hollywood is
known as faction or fiction couched in a
context of facts but different from the
work of some fellow travelers in the
world of hoaxes we just wanted to design
and then congratulate the world on
having had the better idea all along we
hope to spread rumors that the world had
changed operating just as the right wing
does with all the guises but
the disadvantages of truce so it might
not be entirely clear if this high-speed
rail line between LA and Las Vegas the
desert express or this high-speed rail
line between LA Vegas and Phoenix is the
real project and it might seem strange
to build a high-speed rail in the desert
but it actually makes absolute sense
given that the 500-mile train journey
Trump's the same distance by air given
that it frequently costs more to build a
runway then could pass on my capacity
than a train line this was Russ Maeda
and Tom Moran gathered this research BPL
and if you believe that here was a
project from my research about the ways
in which the floor is becoming the most
important architectural surface it
showed new vehicles that are the murders
of cars elevators and automated guided
vehicles in the same way that they out
that an elevator was an active form that
dictated most of our urban morphology
these devices have I think a tremendous
capacity to generate morphology if
mostly because they alter what
constitutes navigable surface in
architecture they don't need shafts or
roads or drivers they go horizontally
and vertically and if anything they
favor the floor because they read the
floor for instructions my favorite one
is this is this one here but it's like a
giant roll cell things kind of coming
towards either 11 miles an hour
and if you believe that you might leave
this plan to use the Amazon to bypass
the Panama Canal and take down oil and
and along the route in Ecuador the
Yasuni preserve is a particularly
species abundant area and it's sitting
on 20% of the country's oil but it's
been the subject of a new global oil
protocol it's something like red that
you may know about but it's not an
offset for admissions it actually sells
certificates to the world in exchange
for keeping its oil in the ground
Santiago del carro gathered this
research and of course OPEC wants to buy
certificates you know for obvious
reasons and if you believe that I can I
can tell you about some research I've
been doing that indicates really clearly
that building subtraction as both a
heavy industry and the design program
protocol is an emergent global
enterprise that's capable of making
negative development profitable so I
think this is the removal of buildings
is going to be an incredibly lucrative
new Enterprise prompted by the financial
crisis these emergent subtraction
economies allow the building that the
sort of physical outcropping of the
real-estate market to approach the
flexibility and volatility of the
throbbing financial envelope that's
that's surrounding it so I'm working on
two active forms here one is a
marketplace for material recovery after
subtraction and the other is a new
playbook for gaming space and part of
what I'm doing is simply putting
together what already exists as they
work together they position negative
development
as an aggressive lucrative industry so
I'm I'm saying that the new flipper the
new quant
is making money from building removal
and the glimmers of this emergent
industry or you know not surprisingly on
HDTV you've seen demo men and then you
know where we always see it of course
computer and iPhone apps you know
somehow it has to already be obvious
somehow it has to order be right in
front of us all along to really seem you
know outlandish but the material
marketplace that I'm working on is a
little bit like joint which you've
probably seen it's a GPS enabled version
of eBay or Amazon or a little bit like
Google traitor in Tanzania
it creates an online marketplace of
sorts except that in you Inc you're
giving things away but I'm working with
bonobo the developers of Yoink on a
similar app that will trade sell handle
spent construction materials actually I
noticed that somebody on your ink is
actually already doing this giving away
you know lumber but it's called stream
and it works in a very similar way so
rather than engage with EPA's glacial
reforms about material streams are
engaged in some quixotic effort to
reform recycling the app just allows
entrepreneurs to harvest materials
formerly known as waste which are
incredibly lucrative and but none of
that negative development I don't think
would ever be you know lucrative because
of a material marketplace so really more
powerful is a growing number of
development protocols for site clearing
that and there's been a lot of it right
that spatialized risk and property
interdependence so I've found a
subtraction playbook let's call it that
stabilizes development investment by
deleting development and I think
paired with the material marketplace
what I mean by that is well you know how
herbal forks Savannah grew by Ward's
so they were explicitly designed squares
but each time you built a square
it came with a quotient of rural space
outside the city so it would grow it's
an active form it would grow and you
knew explicitly how it would grow but
you would you could never name it you
could never tell what its outline would
be and the subtraction protocol I'm
talking about you can't oh I'm sorry
that you can barely see I know if you
can see the X the space is outside the
can you see it just vaguely right I'll
do it again can you see that there's
spaces outside yeah they're the rules
but so that's what what happened in
Savannah but but what I'm talking about
is one that works in the reverse of
Savannah so the combination of
demolition and densifying has always
been profitable but this PlayBook uses
the taxes on increased profit from
densification to purchase Lots or
buildings for deletion and it allows
those two sets of Lots to have shares in
each other's profits profits from
densification and profits from cleared
land that might be doing things like you
know either either getting profits from
landscape or energy or utility business
and it's intended for excessive spent
development but some of these
interdependencies might also be applied
to the more violent subtractions in
sensitive sites but it's anyway it shows
how throwing the development engine in
Reverse can make a subtraction a forum
of growth and in some ways completely
obvious but the best way for me to
illustrate maybe is to show you this
this reverse game of go that you may
have seen
called take away its diverse and reverse
of go because it values clearing rather
than obstruction I don't know if any of
you have played this can you see enough
contrast there and see you
again it's always already there always
all around us
to close to see native and as the layers
of global infrastructure become more
pallet palpable they tutor a political
craft the dispositional strata of
infrastructure are politically powerful
in that they can disappear and be
discrepant but they can also serve as
the weather changing matrix changing
medium that decides what survives active
forms continually conditioned space with
political intent I mean I think you
could say they show us how to game space
and in this central and potent territory
our underexplored under exploited forms
of polity that are eminent in the back
channels of global infrastructure thank
you
questions
it's actually it different it were a
while and during innocence was a series
of stories this is asking this is
actually generating a contemplation
first about about disposition and using
using about disposition and also about
this sort of dominant FS teens the ways
in which they provide the ways in which
the case studies provide contradiction
to them but it's structured there's
three parts but it's the three of the
main stories are I so the Kenya story
and the zone story but they're each of
them a kind of tangle of infrastructure
not not following any one network
my question
you have admitted this this room active
or how does it relate it is
Gosei system or or gets us like torture
and as in likes work she was ever
proposed as a postive built structure is
it Those or is it a thing that you which
is kind of like them there's many forms
of authorship which we which are we
don't enjoy as much as we might and
those are you know you mentioned
structure a system but of course those
things slide between many things that we
regard a site proper but the pleasure
and populations of those sites the
pleasure and components that travel the
pleasure in remote toggles that alter
something physically but but they
they're not drawing our our direct
shaping and contouring but indirect
shaping and contouring I think those are
really thrilling modes of authorship
with a completely different species of
artistry but equally satisfying I think
we do tend to think of them as well
that's you know its construction and
structure and system is always different
but I mean as is obvious here
I'm using the way in which you know for
instance in theater that's completely
natural Hut's that you you offered me
off of your make and you're making
action
you're not making profile you love
profile that you love text you love
words in the sound of them but you you
love making action with that too you're
up to your elbows in action when you go
to work and that's a pleasure that I
think we do not take advantage of a
seduction we do not succumb to
you have no other questions you don't
even want to ask me what's true how do
you describe it what I meant by that and
that was a sort of a glancing - quick
comment but I I was trying to say that
the this form of subtraction that I was
showing I was trying to distance it from
forms of subtraction that we usually see
which have to do with clearing slum
clearing you know this long history of
the ways in which there are violence
economies of subtraction around the
world and this while this protocol I'm
talking about is aimed that kind of
McMansion excesses it I think there is
something about the inner dependency
between and and sharing of risk inner
dependency between properties that could
potentially be be used in in a reverse
of the subtraction of protocol so not
the SoDo right not that which you know
has its own problems just just
accelerates a number of problems not
giving deeds you know but but creating
dependencies could you feed an
imagination with a an idea like that a
political imagination
do you take an ethical position on truth
versus fiction or fact versus spin or
doesn't matter really like when you talk
about right-wing tactics of kind of
using obviously false facts to generate
more interest than those false facts to
generate some kind of interest it
doesn't matter
is there an ethical kind of is there
still like an ethical desire with truth
or it does not matter well that's not I
suppose it's not about being
deliberately misleading in some kind of
vino way but but learning but learning
the way in which the sort of forthright
position is that it is that a
disadvantage doesn't mean that one has
to live but that being able to create
forms that are that are fluid that are
mediagenic that are travelling is is
much more powerful and then the right
wing does that brilliantly coming up
with different names for things coming
up with a kind of spin so I mean your
question is interesting because you know
I'm trying to say that it's that that
certainty about principles that this is
not the ethical stance that I would
it's the struggle with them it's the one